i am here to talk about parallel
programming
or not but before that i wanted to show
you
the ugliest program i ever wrote
here it is
[Applause]
i wrote this program 40 years ago for a
computer the ibm 1130
about as big as a desk in fact it
physically was a desk
had 16-bit words it had one 32-bit
register
actually the high 16 bits were called
the accumulator and the low 16 bits were
called the accumulator extension
and its main job was to hold the uh the
32-bit result will multiply instruction
otherwise it was a 16-bit computer
had 4096 words of memory that made it an
eight kilobyte main memory
ran a full fortran four compiler as well
as other interesting software
here's a closer view of the front
console of the 1130
it had a keyboard down there at the
bottom that you can see and a bunch of
big fat
lights and big fat push buttons i missed
those square push buttons
uh the big black box above it and below
the the
the panel of lights is the console
printer this is a modified selectric
typewriter that had one of those
electromechanical golf balls that would
strike out characters one at a time on
the paper
and on the front of the console printer
there are 16 data entry switches that
you can
see just in case you needed to enter
some data into the computer you had
these switches
this program that i showed you on this
hollerith card
was actually designed for fortran code
but i used it for another purpose
and this would go into a card reader
that looks something like this another
big hulking piece of a big iron
equivalent in size to the cpu
desk a little taller and it
could read and punch 80 column cards and
it also has a special program load mode
which is where this comes in
the way you bootstrap the system was to
load one of these cards into the card
reader
and then hit the program load button on
the console and
the card reader would suck in one card
and dump 80 words of data into the
memory and then start that at location
zero
and usually the job of this program was
of one of these cards
was to contain an i o driver that would
either read more cards or
read a bootstrapping program off of the
disk drive or something
but sometimes little utility programs
were written on these cards
and the job of this particular program
was to do a core dump
now this idea was not original with me
ibm had a version of this program but i
wanted to improve upon it
ibm's version would read a 16-bit
address from the switches
and then start that would print that
address on the console printer
as a record and then start dumping data
at that location printing it out one
word at a time
is four hexadecimal digits and uh
being able to do this is pretty
important because this is back in the
battle days before
separation between supervisor mode and
user mode it was very easy for a user
mode program
to execute some random cons constant and
halt the
cpu in order to figure out what happened
taking a core dump was very helpful
and because there were only four
thousand words of memory you could dump
all of memory
onto the printer and it only took about
four and a half pages to print and then
you could take it off your desk and you
know pour over the hexadecimal listing
try to figure out what had happened
it was literally possible to inspect
every bit of the main memory and try to
figure out what was going on back in
those days
that's impossible now because things
have gotten so big
now uh i found ibm's version awkward to
use because it printed one address and
then all this long string of data
and when you were three thousand words
along it was hard to tell what address
it was what
so i want an improved version that would
format the printed data better
by first printing a new line ibm's
version didn't even do that
then print the address then 16 words of
data then another new line
the address incremented by 16 16 more
words of data and so forth so does it
get a nice tabular format
and then there's an extra fill up to
print the addresses in red and the data
in black because i was fascinated by the
two color
ribbon in this electric typewriter
okay so i wanted to uh i would like to
show you the original source code for
this but unfortunately i seem to have
lost it
this is all i've got so um
there's my ugly program well
i spent this last weekend reverse
engineering it which is an interesting
exercise doing forensics on your own
code from 40 years ago
so the first step in doing this is to
flip the card over like this
so you can read off the columns as rows
and and we see them as binary words now
when
uh card data is ordinarily read into the
computer it's read in this
format thing you need to realize is that
it was a 16-bit computer but the card
has only 12 rows you only get 12 bits of
data
and normally when you're trying to read
character data
you pull in the the 12 bits from the
card into the high order 12 bits of the
word in the low order four gets up to
zero
but in the special program mode load it
gets read in this funky way
yeah five into the high seven into the
low one of the bits gets duplicated and
three in the middle gets set to zero
which seems utterly insane until you
take a look at the instruction format
for the ibm 1130
which is five bits of opcode eight bits
of sine displacement that tells you
where the operand
is that displacement is added to the
address of the instruction plus one
y plus one well because the instruction
counter is always kept one ahead
of the instruction you're executed
computing so the displacement gets added
to the instruction counter
and there's also this uh this long mode
bit which if one says the instruction
really takes two words
but uh the card always sets it to zero
and there are two bits of index register
field uh this
uh besides the accumulator there are
architecturally three index registers
they're actually implemented as main
memory locations so i didn't count them
earlier
okay so that's why the card is read in
this format so with this understanding
we can draw vertical lines on the card
which is something i literally do
and did back in those days so as to
separate the card
the card rows into the groups
corresponding to hexadecimal digits
and then you do the uh the long and
tedious work of transcribing the holes
on the card into hexadecimal like that
so down the left hand column i show you
the addresses in hexadecimal to which
they'll be loaded in the computer's
memory
and on the right-hand side the
transcription of the data on the card
and you will notice that in the second
column of the transcribed data the digit
is always eight or zero
and in the third column the high two
bits of the digit are always the same
because that's what you are able to read
in one of these cards
now not all instructions fit this format
if you want to have an
instruction in your program that uses
the long format or uses an index
register
you can't represent it on the cards if
you need that instruction you will have
to devote instructions on the card to
constructing those other instructions
that's okay self-modifying code is a way
of life on the 11 30.
okay so let's take a look at how one
analyzes this code i've
taken the transcribed hexadecimal and
just so it'll fit on the slide organized
into three columns
and then i did the the second tedious
process of getting out my old ibm 1130
functional characteristics manual
and transcribing the op codes many of
which i still remembered after 40 years
but not all of them
and so i got this as a provisional
transcription of the code
i say provisional because there are some
things in there that i didn't understand
anymore i remembered it was ugly code
that's why i wanted to show it to you
and that's why i undertook the exercise
and by the way while i'm confident of my
transcription of the op codes and of the
behavior of this code i'm not confident
that i have reconstructed
the precise labels for the instructions
that i used when i was a teenager
i tried to reconstruct the zeitgeist and
did my best
okay but there's some funny things for
example if you look at what's going at
address zero zero
two five which is about ten down in the
second column
there's this label get word g-e-t-w-t
and i've transcribed that as a defined
constant of 8 0
c 4. it could be transcribed as an add
instruction because 8-0 is the op code
for add
but there's a negative displacement
there that points to somewhere before
the beginning of the card so that can't
be right
so i know there's something funny going
on there also i'm going to click back a
couple slides
several slides when i first looked at
this card i saw this region
in the upper right where the first five
rows of the card were empty
and to the trained eye that suggests
there's a data table lurking there
because
zero up codes uh normally mean hopefully
computer
so uh in this transcription that
suspicion turns out to be correct
uh so i've transcribed that in the right
hand column with something called table
and if you look at the codes there c4
fcdb
these are in fact the console printer
codes for printing a zero a one a two
and so forth all the hexadecimal digits
up to f except that b
and c aren't right one of them is an
invalid console printer code the other
is a console printer code for a period
so something else is going on there as
well
by the way i speak of console printer
codes because in those days every i o
device had its own
idiosyncratic character set code that
you had to use to talk to it
and doing the translations among the
codes for the different devices was a
job for
a computer you couldn't afford to put
another computer in the i o device do
the translation for you
and these uh console printer code for
example the bits of it
are related to the physical motions of
this electric type ball
so that's what that's about okay so this
is the preliminary disassembly and after
getting this preliminary transcription
and studying it for a while i realized
that or half remembered that there are
chunks of code near the beginning of the
card that serve as this initialization
code whose job
is to modify other parts of the card
probably because there are
bit patterns that could not be
represented directly on the card
and if you hand simulate this what this
code does until you have finished
doing the first six instructions and
then at
address seven there's a branch
instruction around a little chunk that
takes you to the place called more down
at
address f and then there's some more
initialization code and when the
initialization code is finished
we see that um the areas of the card
that i have highlighted here
have either been rewritten or at least
repurposed
so eight eight locations got rewritten
and now we'll see that hooray the table
is correctly organized it has the
console printer codes for the characters
b and c
but uh but there are some other bits in
the high order bits there that may have
a purpose down the line as we shall see
now once this code has been rewritten
there are parts of the initialization
code that are simply not needed anymore
and i've blacked those out on this slide
that is code that is no longer needed
and this is now the final code that was
really intended to be executed this is
the program that does the console
printer core dump
and if we study it further we see that
there are in fact three subroutines here
plus the table
in the first column there is this uh
routine called
chapert which whose job is to print one
character
then in the middle starting at the
bottom of the first column and
continuing to the second column
is the main program loop and the third
part is a subroutine beginning at uh
wdprt at address 002d
so we're going to take a look at each of
these subroutines and see what's going
on
so let's look at this print character
subroutine uh you come in
at location chapert with a bsi
instruction branch and store instruction
counter
now this is not only in the days before
supervisor user mode separation and
before virtual membrane before a bunch
of other things
it was also before stacks we've gotten
used to having stacks and architectures
but back in those days the um i mean
stacks weren't really a well understood
thing
when these computers are being designed
so the accepted practice was simply to
store the return address in memory
in in the location before the first
instruction the subroutine and then
you'd carry on from there and then you
had to do a branch indirect
uh back through that stored instruction
uh return address location
and we will see instead of using an
indirect branch we're going to use a
different technique here
so we come at chapert shift accumulator
left by eight
store the character at location char
which is address one
and then do an xio instruction this is
execute i o
it uses an i o command block at location
right which is at address four
which has contains the address of the
place where i had the character
and then zero nine zero zero is the
command of the console printer print
this character
hurrah and then we execute this constant
16. why are we executing a constant
well the high order bits is zero and
that's good enough to get the computer
to halt and we need to halt
because we need to wait for the
interrupt the console printer will
produce an interrupt and there's no way
to turn off the interrupts
so we have to we have to take the
interrupt so we hope so we execute this
weight instruction at location 16
which leaves the instruction counter
pointing at address c and wait for the
interrupt
well what happens when the interrupt
comes through um oh i had highlighted
this the execute i o instruction happens
and then the um the interrupt comes
through
and the way the inte the
interrupt vectors work is that the level
number of the interrupt gets added to
eight
and you look at that address in the core
memory and their interrupts levels from
zero to five
we happen to know that the console
printer interrupts on level four
therefore its interrupt vector is at
location c
which is eight plus four
and it will pick up the address that is
stored at location c
and branch there in fact do a subroutine
call there thereby storing the current
instruction counter there
well this is a very strange thing
location c in fact points to itself
therefore the instruction counter will
be stored at location c
but this is okay because we carefully
halt it at location b
so the instruction counter contains c so
when it gets stored
the same c will get stored back into
that location and all this just to save
a word so i wouldn't need a separate
halt instruction or something
okay because i've only got 80 words to
work with i've got to cram it onto the
card
okay then we execute another i uh sensei
instruction to tell the console printer
okay i got the character
we branch back up to here and execute
this boss construction
whose job is to do a long branch while
dismissing the interrupt on the
processor side
and this it is a long format instruction
that got constructed by the
initialization code
the second word of the instruction is in
fact the deposited return address at
location chavert
and so we can branch but what's this z
sitting there well the z
is a conditional bit this says don't do
the branch if the accumulator is zero
but i always want to branch well if you
look at the encoding of the instruction
the hexadecimal 4c60
and then trace it back to the
initialization code you'll see it was
constructed from a constant
whose bits came from that duplicated bit
in bits eight and nine
one of those bits is the zero bit and
the other is the dismiss the interrupt
bit i needed to dismiss the interrupt
and i had to take the z bit along with
it fortunately the accumulator is always
non-zero at this point so everything's
okay
i happen to know that
okay now let's look at the main program
uh i have rearranged the code slightly
so the main program is all on the second
column here
and it begins at location loop and uh
one of the things that's going on here
is that um uh there are a couple of
counters one's the word counter wd
wd cnt that's initialized um that
normally starts at 16 and counts down to
zero and that will tell us
when we need to print an address and do
the new line
and also there is this location called
loc loc which is in fact the data that
got read
right in from the switches telling us
what address to print and that's at
address 18.
okay and these counters get incremented
or decremented simply by loading up into
accumulator
adding or subtracting this thing at
location right
and then storing it back what's the
location right look back at the first
column that's location four
write contains the address of char which
i needed for that i o block
i had carefully placed the variable
chart location one
so i can use this address also as a
constant one for bumping counters up and
down
okay and you can see that highlighted on
this slide
now uh another thing that needs to go on
is that before
printing the address i need to do a new
line on the console printer and also
shift the ribbon from black to red and
that's done by loading the constant
location e hack which is showing down
there at the bottom of the second column
it's actually off
somewhere in the table remember remember
the the character e had some funny high
order bits
well by picking up that bit pattern
rotating it by 11 and then using that as
a console printer character
i issue the correct control code so so
in effect that
the the same bits are serving both as
part of the letter e and as part of the
new line shift to red character
now let's take a look at what's going on
in the print word subroutine
uh the main loop does fairly obvious
things uh picking up words and calling
this print word routine in various ways
again the instruction addresses stored
at location wood pert there
at location 2d and it uses also uses
this boss construction as the
is the technique for returning that was
convenient because the initialization
routine had to construct that boss
construction
and then was able to store it in two
different places now what's ugly about
this
is that once again the z bit is set so i
have to be real sure that the
accumulator is non-zero as i'm returning
and it's also dismissing the interrupt
even though i'm not in an interrupt
routine but that's okay it turns out the
processor ignores that
okay so that's a little confusing but it
all works
now let's take a look at how it is uh
counting the hex digits the job of this
uh
little subroutine is to uh
take a data word in the accumulator and
print its four hex digits
it actually rotates it right by 16 at
address two
e thereby putting in the extension and
shifts up four digits at a time
uses that to index into the table of hex
digits then prints the hex digits by
calling
the character print routine but it needs
to count the hex digits it needs to be
able to count up to four
so it loads x4 and uses that to
initialize the digit count
and then further down there at address
37 it loads the digit count back up
subtracts x1 stores it back again uses
this conditional skip instruction to
decide whether we're done and if we're
not done
we use the mdx instruction mdx stands
for branch
and goes back up the location again and
goes around the loop
don't ask okay what about these
locations x1 and x4 that are being used
to do it um well they're instructions
one is this shift left instruction by
four that's at x1
and the other is this subroutine call
instruction to japan off in the main
program loop that's labeled x4
why am i doing that well i have the
constant one available location right
but i didn't have another word on the
card to represent four
so instead i picked up these
instructions and x1
its opcode is about 1000 hexadecimal and
x4
is about 4000 hexadecimal and this is
good enough to drive a counter to four
that's fine but i'm relying on the bit
patterns in those op codes
the other slightly strange thing going
on here is that at location again
it's clearing the accumulator and the
normal idiom for this is to shift the
accumulator right by 16
thereby shifting out all the bits but
here i'm shifting it by 37 locations
turns out that's okay the processor will
do it it takes longer because it's doing
it one clock cycle at a time
so it takes 37 cycles to shift those
bits out but hey
i'm dealing with a console printer it's
only 15 characters per second i got time
but why 37 well look further down here
at the bottom it's loading up that
instruction and then calling the
character print routine ah
this instruction is getting printed as a
character and 37 decimal is 25
hexadecimal which is exactly the code
for
shifting making the console printer
print a space and shift the ribbon to
black
so that's what's going on there once
again saving a word i've only got 80
words to work with
okay
so um there's one other dirty trick i
was pulling which is that
ibm in its manuals documented seven
distinct console printer control codes
and said this is the character you
printed this is the character you print
to do
that something i did as a teenager was
to realize that there were individual
microcoded bits there
and that was probably a bad idea to tell
the printer to both space and backspace
at the same time
probably i could get away with spacing
and shifting to black at the same time
and empirically it worked no ibm
documentation ever countenanced that but
hey okay so we're laughing at this code
it's i'm glad that you're laughing at
some of these tricks and i want to
return to that laughter later
but first i would like to show you
another program for a completely
different computer a pdp-10
of roughly the same era the early 1970s
is a more civilized computer it did have
the user mode supervisor mode
distinction
it had 36-bit words it had 16 registers
instead of one
it was about one one mega ops
per second had about one megabyte of
memory and cost about one mega buck
these are nice round figures to remember
okay the the subroutine i would like to
show you is a very clever and tiny
routine
space efficient way for computing the
height trigonometric sign of an angle
so we are going to use this triple angle
formula for sine you can read you
probably learn double angle formulas
when you're in high school
and from that you can fairly easily
derive this triple angle formula sine of
3x equals 3 sine x minus 4
times the sine of x cubed
by rearranging this and substituting a
over minus 3 for x
we can get this modified version of the
formula that tells us we can compute
sine of a
if only we can compute the sine of a
over minus three
and then and then do this polynomial
computation on it
and here is the code
the argument comes in in register a and
we're going to use register b as a
second
second working register
and we're going to set up an interesting
contract on the subroutine the argument
comes in register a and we will return
the sign of a
and register b we're also going to
promise to return a value in register b
that is either the sine of a or it's
negative
that is we promise to get the magnitude
right but the sign the s
s i g n sine bit might be off
okay so we're going to use them in the
first line we use a move magnitude
instruction that takes the absolute
value of a inputs in b
we compare that absolute value to this
tiny constant .00017
carefully chosen so that if the argument
is smaller than that
then you can say that sine of x is x
to within 27 bits so if the if the
argument is small enough we just return
it that's close enough
otherwise we divide a by -3 in the
fourth line
call ourselves recursively with a
push-jump instruction that pushes the
return address onto the stack call
ourselves back thereby computing the
sign of a
over minus three this bottoms out when
eventually after repeatedly dividing a
by minus three its magnitude gets small
enough
and when we come back remember that we
have not only
the sine of a over minus three and a but
we also have its magnitude possibly the
sign
incorrect in register b so we can use a
multiply instruction to square what's in
b
we don't care about the sign because
that now becomes positive thereby
getting
there by squaring that sign we then
multiply it by 4 with a floating scale
instruction scaling its exponent by 2
we add the constant minus 3 to b and
then there comes this multiply
instruction in the ninth line
that multiplies a and b together and the
b
on the end of fm prb is an addressing
mode that means put the result
in both places which is a really handy
thing thereby satisfying our contract
the sign of a
comes back in a and its magnitude with
some sign bit
comes back in register b so the whole
thing fits in 10 instructions or
49-bit bytes if you want to measure it
that way
it's a model of elegance it's not
numerically terribly accurate but it's
good it's okay for a lot of applications
and i view this as one of the early
poems of
of the early computer era it has a
certain understated elegance it doesn't
need any extra working registers it just
uses registers a and b
and uses this sort of very clever
mathematical technique
this came out in 1972 it was published
in a famous memo called hackmen that had
all kinds of interesting small
subroutines
but something about it bugged me over
the years and 25 years later i found an
improvement
in the mid 90s which is to realize that
that constant there
in the second line by the way that
constant is in square brackets and those
square brackets are interesting because
what they
they tell the assembler please put this
constant in some other word of memory
for me i don't care where
and make this this instruction point to
its address
this is an interesting piece of
abstraction compared with the ibm 1130
code
where for every constant i had to pick a
particular place to put it this gives me
a way to say
i don't care any address will do that's
an important kind of abstraction
okay so here's this constant point zero
zero zero one seven i realize that was
small enough that its exponent probably
didn't have the high order bit turned on
it was small enough that
that its bit pattern was probably an
octal two zero
zero i know those bit patterns those are
the floating point instructions
because of course i also know the bit
patterns most of the pdb10 instructions
so quickly i evaluated all the floating
point instructions in here and realized
that
the floating point multiply instruction
was just about right in fact if you can
arrange for register b to be register 11
then the value of that instruction as a
floating point constant is .000167
which is close enough to be good enough
and that's how you can finally after 25
years
knock four bites off the size of this
routine
much too late to be of use of anybody
but i felt good about it for a while and
then i realized maybe i've really
desecrated a diamond here
because while i have in fact made it
smaller i've also made it
much less understandable and much less
[Applause]
maintainable
and that matters there's a trade-off
here it wasn't 100
perfect
this brings me to the theme of my talk i
want to talk about the automation of
resource management in computer software
and over the years since the bad old
days we've seen a constant improvement
in the kinds of ways we write our
programs and the kind of infrastructure
we use to do that
way back in the beginning at the time of
anyak people simply
wrote their programs as strings of
decimal or octal or hexadecimal digits
and then came along the technique of
assemblers which allowed you to use
names for the instructions and perhaps
also provided
names labels for the instructions so
that you didn't have to
make a decision about what the
displacement instruction what the
address instruction be
you tell the assembler all i care about
is that this instruction has the address
of of this data location and i don't
typically want to worry about its
numerical value
i'll just give a name to it you take
care of the details
then came the idea of a relocating
assembler which not only took the
symbolic form of your of your machine
language program
and translated into desolate hexadecimal
or or bits or whatever
but also kept track of whether each
location contained an address or not
and then a linker could take the program
move it to a different location in
memory
use the information from december about
which ones were addresses to update the
addresses
and thereby make it feasible to bind
together separately assembled
subroutines and have them all work
together
that depended on the programmer in
effect saying not only do i not care
about the numerical
value of this address i really don't
care where in memory the program is
placed
it should still work so once again what
used to be a very important concern to
the program was a great concern of mine
when writing
this code because i was taking advantage
of numerous puns between addresses and
data
we got more maintainable and more
reusable code by releasing some of those
concerns to automated tools
and then came other technologies the
compilation of expressions so i didn't
have to worry about the order in which
instructions were coded i just said
i want to i want to compute here's an
expression quantum compute compiler you
take care of the details
register allocation became something to
delegate the compiler
the rise of stacks and the use of stacks
to contain not only return addresses but
also local data
heat management this required writing in
a style where you say not only do i
not know what address my code is at i
don't care what address my data is at
and in fact i don't even want a way to
find out what the address of the data is
you take care of it i delegate the
details
virtual memory address remapping all of
these are ways of
letting the programmer release concerns
to the automated technology
so the main point of this talk is how
can we
release the concerns of parallelism to
the automated technology
how can we let go of the details that we
have been obsessing about
for two or three decades at this point
and my thesis is that the best way to
write parallel applications is not to
have to think about parallelism
just as the best way to to deal with
data and its
management is not to have to worry about
its management you have this garbage
collector let it deal with it
now sometimes you can't release all the
concerns and sometimes you do need some
controls but for the most part from
most kinds of code we can have a
separation of concerns and delegate some
of these problems
now i want to distinguish between
parallelism and concurrency here
there are some kinds of code which are
modeling things going on in the real
world
and um uh are connected with other
processes that you have no control over
you know other people the internet that
kind of thing that calls for concurrency
usually those are situations where you
have different things going on at the
same time
and they're competing for resources
they're competing for processors they're
competing for memory for for a database
for the user's attention but there's
some form of competition
i'm talking about parallelism where
there's one task at hand
but you have many resources and you're
trying to bring all those resources to
bear
to solve one problem and they're working
cooperatively rather than competitively
and in a typical application there are
some parts that need to be concurrent
there are some parts where you really
care that something be sequential i
really care that this happens in this
than this
and there's a large mass in the middle
where it doesn't have to be sequential
it doesn't have to be strictly
concurrent but if there are parallel
resources that we brought to bear we'd
like to do that
and do it effectively without having to
worry too much about it and i thought a
lot about about what
are the consequences of that for our
programming style and what about our
traditional programming styles might be
obstructing
the effective use of parallelism
and there are several things but the one
i'm going to harp on in this talk
is the design pattern of the accumulator
and i'm going to argue that accumulators
have served us extremely well
for 50 years they're very effective on
sequential
architectures there's a reason why that
register in the ibm 1130 was called
an accumulator it was something you
initialize to zero and then you add
things in one at a time
and then you'd have the sum but going
forward on multiple computers i think
accumulators are sort of a bad data
organization strategy
and divide and conquer is going to have
to take its place this is an old meth
message it's been studied by the
academics for 40 50 years
but now is the time to start taking it
seriously and furthermore in order to
make this effective understanding
certain algebraic properties of your
code is going to be important
and programmers need to help ensure
these properties
for debugging reproducibility is also
very important we'd like not to have
asynchrony
mess up the behavior of a program i'm
not going to talk too much more about
that in this talk but it's a point i
wanted to make
so what is it that makes code good well
we've got intuitive metrics for this
good sequential code that was trying to
be fast typically minimizes the total
number of operations executed because
minimizing that number is a good proxy
for optimizing speed on a sequential
computer
and so we tend to use clever algorithmic
tricks to reuse previously computed
results rather than recomputing things
in
new but good parallel code will often
have to perform redundant operations
in order to reduce communication
sometimes a processor is better off
recomputing something for itself
than trying to borrow something another
processor did so there's a trade-off
here between computation and
communication costs
also good sequential algorithms will try
to minimize space usage and there are a
lot of algorithms in literature that use
clever tricks
to reuse storage a lot of sorting
algorithms involve
tricks for reusing storage so you can
sort the array in place rather than
using extra temporary storage
good parallel code will also often
require extra space
extra memory to permit temporal
decoupling
and finally and this is the main point i
want to talk about these first two have
to do with resource usage but i want to
talk about programming
style sequential idioms tend to stress a
linear
problem decomposition that requires
sequential execution
you process one thing at a time and
accumulate the results and i think the
good parallel code is going to require
multi-way problem decomposition and
multi-way aggregation
results in a nutshell i'm arguing for
map reduce
in the small as well as in the large as
we shall see
so let's add a bunch of numbers and
let's assume we want to bring parallel
resources to bear
okay i've written this do loop in um in
a language similar to fortran which i
call
fortran
and i like lots of different languages
so i tend to mix them up in my talks
okay so here's a do loop that takes i
from one to a million
and uh for each value of i it
indexes into an array x grabs x sub i
and adds it into the sum
can this code be parallelized and my
answer is who cares it's buggy
i forgot to initialize the sum
this is actually something that bugs me
pun intended about
the accumulator design pattern is that
it's so easy to forget to initialize
uh okay so can this code be paralyzed
yes it can
but the way this code is organized is
already bad
and good clever parallelizing compilers
have to undo this and say
oh i see what he's really trying to do
and there are
people such as fran allen who won the
turing award a few years ago
for her work a lifetime of work on
making such clever paralyzing compilers
taking raw fortran code and making it
run in parallel on parallel computers
had to know an awful lot about these
loops and what you could get away with
doing in the way of program
transformation
you realize the programmer really
doesn't care in what order i
i add them into the accumulator in fact
i could make several accumulators one
per processor and have each of them add
up part of it and add it up
then add up their sums at the end i can
play games like that
well maybe i can floating point numbers
are tricky business and sometimes that's
okay and sometimes it isn't
i'm going to finesse the problems of
floating point today and assume that
we're dealing with integers
now what does a mathematician say uh to
add up a bunch of numbers
well there's this big sigma notation it
just says for i from 1 to a million i
want to add up the x sub i's and i'm not
going to
specify here how that is to be done and
it's okay not to specify how because i
know that addition is associative and
commutative
and therefore the order doesn't matter
and the way i group them doesn't matter
in fact the the mathematician might have
not even bother with the indexing
apparatus it might just say
there's this vector x add them up done
i don't want to think about the details
now fortran 90
eventually introduced library routines
such as sum that let you do exactly this
and other library routines such as max
and count you would find the largest
value or count the number of non-zero
values capital number true values that
kind of thing
and i think this is an advance and
abstraction because it says what you
want to do without specifying an
obsessive detail
how there's no commitment yet as to the
necessary execution strategy
and for the bulk of programming that's a
good thing
so now let's look at the sequential
computation tree that is literally
described by this do loop
i'm going to abstract away the indexing
apparatus and just look at the
expression tree that is implicitly built
up on the fly by the execution of this
loop
of the addition operations involving sum
so sum is initialized to zero
then we add an x sub one then we add an
x sub two then we add an x sub three
and all the way up to adding in x sub a
million
now how could we parallelize this code
well a strategy that was explored quite
heavily in the 80s and 90s and it's
still used today
is to say well let's put an annotation
on the do loop and say
uh it's okay with me if the uh
body of the do loop if it's various
iterations are computed in parallel
because i really don't care about their
ordering so you slap a parallel
keyword on it and then ask whether this
does the job and the answer is who cares
it's got a bug in it there's a race
condition
if i turn all million executions of this
body loose
say i've got a million processors to
bear and suppose they just accidentally
all run at the same speed then they all
pick up the value of some
you know competing with in the memory
interfaces because it's become a hot
spot
they finally get the value of sum they
add their own value of x sub i
then they store it all back into some
and boom most of the additions have been
lost
so this is a bad race condition and we
fix it by putting an atomic keyword on
the body
now the code is correct again but
unfortunately it's no longer parallel
what we have said here
is that all the updates can be done in
some order and i don't care what the
order is
but they still have to be sequential so
here's a possible computation tree that
might result what we really want is a
computation tree that looks like this
you know something like more like a
balanced binary tree this will allow us
to use parallelism down near the leaves
of the tree
and thereby do the whole computation in
a time that is more like
log of a million than like a million and
since
you know log base two of a million is uh
20 that's you know an improvement to
something like 50 000 so that would be
good
assuming of course we could bring enough
processing power to bear
okay so let's contrast accumulation with
divide and conquer
the idea behind accumulation is that you
start with an empty solution
and then as you bring each input in you
use each input to incrementally update
the solution
and what i want to draw your attention
to is the fact that this incremental
update operator is typically asymmetric
it takes an input and an accumulation
and produces a new accumulation
the two arguments are of different types
this strategy is terrific if you're
committed to using one processor
because while it uses linear linear time
which is fine if you only get one
processor
it really saves space and avoids
constructing data structures that was
the attraction of the accumulator
the strategy in divide and conquer is to
be able to process
each of the inputs separately without
regard to this accumulating value
so the strategy is you look at each
input separately construct a singleton
solution
and then figure out how to merge these
solutions to make bigger solutions
until finally when you've merged them
all you've got the complete solution
notice that the combining operator in
this case
is symmetric with respect to its data
types it takes two solutions and
produces a new solution
now this typically takes more space but
it can be log time
and intermediate solutions may need to
be heaped allocated so there are some
engineering tradeoffs here
merge is also usually more complicated
operation than the incremental update
we'll see examples of that later on in
the talk
but on the other hand the merge operator
typically is associative
often it is also commutative but it
doesn't have to be but the fact
that you can identify a combining
operation that has this algebraic
property usually lends deeper insight
into the problem
so i'm going to show you an example of a
a parallel code
and also in its sequential form and in
order to fit on the slide i had to
choose a sort of toy example and you may
object that
that my example has hardly any content
as mostly boilerplate and that's true
because i had to fit it on the slides
just as i had to fit a program on to 80
words on the 11 30 and having to fit an
example onto eight slides
so bear with me the problem here is
given a character string to produce a
list of strings which are the words in
the original string
that were separated by spaces so we'll
assume that the string just consists of
letters and spaces and not have quibbles
about commas and other funny symbols
the words return must be non-empty so if
we have had to have two spaces together
we won't say there's an empty word in
between then we'll just say there's
there's no word there
so you so words may be separated by
multiple spaces and the strings may or
may not begin or end with spaces
so okay using good test driven
development here are some tests that i
expect to be satisfied
here examples of five strings and the
expected output from my program
and um by the way i am presenting this
code
in a research language that is my
current working project called fortress
it is a programming language that's
originally developed
with an eye towards petaflop scale super
computers but more recently it's been
retargeted more towards
mid-range multi-cores and clusters and
the main
design features of this language are
there were our user extensibility
so we have the possibility for example
of operator overloading and
uh extensible data types and things like
that
the second principal design principle is
to try to
support traditional mathematical
notation whatever makes sense or
traditional domain-specific notation
therefore we support all of unicode and
in particular user-defined
overloading of the unicode mathematical
operators and we will make one use of
that in this example
and the third thing is to try to be
parallel whether that makes sense it is
possible to write sequential code it is
possible to write accumulator style code
as we will see
with the languages biased to have a
parallel flavor and finally the whole
thing has object oriented underpinnings
so our goal here is to write a little
routine called words that takes a string
and when called on each of these five
strings such as this is a sample
it will return a list that when when fed
to print line will print
a list in angle brackets this is a
sample
and angle brackets as part of the syntax
of how list is printed in this language
from here is another sample the second
string just shows what happens when you
have multiple blanks sitting around
there you don't get empty words back you
just get those four words
if the string has no spaces in it at all
that's an interesting boundary case to
check we expect to get back a list of
exactly one word
and if the string consists just of
blanks or is empty we expect to get back
an empty list
okay so here is sequential code and this
is i think the sort of sequential code
that i
or anyone in the room who's an
experienced programmer could sit down
and quickly write in about five minutes
in
his favorite programming language and it
probably looks something like this
so i'll walk you through it words is a
function that takes a string
s and uh there's this do block
that first that executes statements in
order so the do block does provide for
sequential processing
and we're going to first initialize two
accumulators one is a result which is a
list of strings and it is initialized to
the empty list
and the other is word which is a string
that's initialized to empty string
and the strat once i show you this data
structure my temporary variables the
strategy should be obvious
we're going to walk through the
character string from left to right
character by character
if we see a non-blank we're going to
append it onto the word and if we see a
blank
then we look to see whether the word
should be appended into the result
so we have this for loop and as k goes
sequentially
from zero starting from zero and for a
number of iterations equal to the length
of the string
we first grab the character that's at
location k and for technical reasons
having to do with simplicity
of code i'm using sub sub strings right
there is a separate character data type
and fortress
but it's easier to work with uh
singleton strings uh just so i'm not
working with multiple data types
so grab the sub string of length one at
location k from the string and call that
char
we check to see whether char is the
blank character
and if it is then we need to see whether
we've actually got a word in hand or not
if the word is empty
if the word is not empty then we need to
accumulate it on a result by using the
concatenation operator
which is a double vertical bar
that serves as both list concatenation
and as
string concatenation so we make a list
of word
and concatenate that onto the result
list and then we reset the word to be
empty
if on the other hand the character is
not empty then we simply append it to
word
down near the bottom when we finish the
loop there's one final fix up
which is that we might have accumulated
a partial word in the accumulator named
word
and we've not yet appended it on the
result so if after we finish the loop
word is not empty then we need to tack
that on to the end of result and then
finally return the result
give everybody clear and roughly how
this code works okay i think i think it
would be considered a simple example for
anyone to code
now let's look at how we might take it
use a divide and conquer strategy on it
so as to get parallel execution
and i admit the parallel execution on a
short string it's only 40 characters
long might not make a lot of sense
but if we're you know millions of
characters long then that application
becomes
interesting so to fit on the slide i've
i've chosen a
40 character sequence here is a
sesquipedalian string of words
carefully chosen to have one nice long
word in it and instead of dividing it up
into 40 individual characters i'm just
going to break it up into four pieces so
you can see the basic strategy
we're going to need data structures to
represent the partial results
of processing these these uh these
sections of the string
so if there's a section of the string
that is all non-blank
such as i've shown here on this slide
sesquipeta
then we're going to represent with with
that with a data structure which i've
arbitrarily labeled
chunk so it is a chunk of a word and
it contains within it that substring
that's all there is to it
on the other hand if we look at the
fourth section of the string
we see that there is definitely a word
in the middle namely the word of
and then g butts up against the
left-hand end of that section
and w-o-r-d-s butts up against the
right-hand section
because we are doing this out of context
we're just focusing on those 10
characters
and aren't looking at the rest of the
string yet we don't know whether these
are complete words or something that
needs to be joined onto something else
to the left or the right to make
complete words
so i'm going to represent this with a
data structure which i'll arbitrarily
call segment
consisting of a left chunk which might
need to be completed into a word on the
left
a list of words in the middle and then a
right chunk that may or may not be
complete
the part up front consists of here is uh
and
this section 10 character section of the
string begins with h-e-r-e it ends with
a blank
so we're able to say definitively that
there are two words in the middle
is an uh and there is no partial chunk
on the right but there is a partial
chunk on the left
i can still represent that in my segment
data structure simply by using an empty
string for the right chunk
and then finally the segment data
structure can handle this fourth fourth
piece of the string
by uh having a left chunk and a right
chunk and an empty list of words in the
middle nothing is definitely a full word
in this portion
we've got something potentially building
up on the left and something potentially
building up on the right
okay so if i can represent partial
solutions using these chunk and data
segments
chunk and segment data structures the
question is can i now merge solutions to
make bigger solutions
and the answer is yes in fact we will
find that combining either ac
combining two segments or two chunks or
a chunk and a segment will still be
representable as either chunk or a
segment
and i'm going to represent their
combination with this o plus operator
that represents the merging of two
solutions so in order to merge
the segment from here is ah and the
chunk sesquipeda
in effect all i have to do is take that
chunk susqueha and have it become the
right chunk of the segment i will
construct a new segment
that matches the old segment but has
been updated with that chunk that is on
the right
similarly uh to merge these two sub
solutions i have two segments
and the trick is to take the right chunk
of the first segment and the left chunk
of the second segment
squish them together to make a word well
if it's not empty it's a word
and then put that in the middle and
append the lists together with that
combined chunk in the middle
so in this case i combined two segments
leanne the empty list in strin
and the segment g the word of and the
chunk
words to make a new segment having a
left chunk lien
two words in the middle string of and
then this partial chunk words on the
right
and then finally those partial th those
two subsolutions can then in turn be
merged
as we get a final solution that is a
segment like this and then we will need
to fix up on each side and declare the
two chunks on either side in fact to be
complete words
and we will get the final list of words
here is a sesquipedalian string of words
okay so that's the data structure what
does the code look like
okay i'm going to leave you through that
in a few slides here
and it may this the programming style
may strike you as a little odd in some
ways
it will also strike you as functional in
style i've chosen to use completely
immutable data structures for this
although fortress is originally designed
as an object-oriented framework in which
to build an
array style scientific programming
language we've in fact found it useful
to build
a variety of of domain specific
languages and as we've experimented with
it and tried to get the parallelism
going
we found ourselves pushed more and more
in the direction of using immutable data
structures in a functional style of
programming
and my haskell fan friends have told me
why didn't you just start with haskell
and i tell them if i'd known seven years
ago what i know now would have started
with haskell
and pushed it a tenth of the way toward
fortran instead of starting with fortran
and pushing it nine tenths of the way
towards
haskell but this is where we've ended up
and that's why it's research
okay so i've taken the standard fix up
pattern and encoded it as a subroutine
here called maybe word
and its job is to take a string s and if
the string is empty it returns an empty
list in otherwise it returns a list of s
in other words it tells me whether or
not s was a word by returning either an
empty list or a list of that word
very common idiom in the style so that
sort of constructs a singleton kind of
solution
now i'm going to define this trait and
for trait you can read the java word
interface
the only difference between a trait in
an interface is that in fortress a trait
may contain
method definitions not just declarations
and you can inherit definitions through
the interface hierarchy
using multiple inheritance fortress is a
multiple inheritance language it's a
multi-method dispatch language
and in those ways it differs and goes
beyond java
so we have this trait called word state
it declares an abstract
user-defined overloaded operator called
o plus
whose job is to take myself and another
word state and make a new word state
okay so this is a combining operator for
merging solutions
word state is the overall name of the
data structure representing a partial
solution of the problem
it's got a couple of other declarations
here it says that word state comprises
chunk and segment
so chunk as we will see chunk implements
word state
segment implements word state and in
fact there aren't any other word states
these
are the only immediate subtypes of word
state and the main purpose of this
declaration is that later when we have
case statements we'll be able to tell
that the case statement
in fact provides an exhaustive
enumeration of possibilities for word
state
the other interesting declaration here
is that word state extends associative
of word state and o plus
these uh these traits may take
parameters static type parameters an
associative
is one that takes another type as its
parameter as well as the name of an
operator symbol
this is a declaration that says i
guarantee that o plus
is in fact an associative operator
algebraically behaves associatively
in other words it doesn't matter how i
group things when i combine them
well it's okay for me to claim that how
does the compiler know that
well i die ideally i would like to be
able to prove that as a theorem that the
technology isn't there yet
so in fact we rely on unit testing and
there's a whole other part of the
language i'm not going to go into now
where you can provide test data and
there's an automated test system will
use the provided test data
and exhaustively check on the test data
whether in fact
the operator does in fact behave
associatively and that is done through
property declarations that look very
much like
first order predicate calculus
statements of the associative property
and that's enough mathematical buzzwords
for today
okay here the implementations of chunk
and segment chunk is an object
and its constructor takes an argument
with s which is a string
which will become a field of the object
in fact and there are two
implementations
of o plus it is overloaded uh in much
the same way that one might one
might one might do in java
getting ahead of myself okay in order to
combine yourself with another chunk you
just take your field s
the other guys s concatenate them
together and make a new chunk
in order to combine yourself a chunk
with a segment
while you construct a new segment in
which you've taken your s and
concatenated
onto the front of the other guy's left
chunk and then you use his list of words
in his right chunk
and that's fine notice that s l a and r
are preserved in the same order this is
how you know you're preserving the
sequence of the original input data
a segment has a left chunk l a right
chunk r both of which are strings and a
middle list
a which is a list of strings it also
extends word state
it has two implementations two
overloadings of o plus in order to
combine yourself a segment with a chunk
you need to take take his string and
concatenate it onto the right of your
right chunk and then make a new segment
and in order to combine new
two segments down there at the bottom
you use the
left chunk of the left hand segment that
is yourself the right hand chunk of the
other guy
and then you need to make a list of
words in the middle consisting of your
list
and then maybe a word in the middle and
then the other guy's list
and that maybe a word in the middle
consists of your right chunk
concatenated his left chunk
once again all the data is kept in the
correct order and you can see that by
the textual order in the code
my l my a my r the other guys l the
other guys a the other guys are
all appear there in order in that line
okay we're about to come to the finish
here one more little utility
routine i showed you that utility
routine maybe word that
helps with the fix-ups at the end and
with a fix up when you combine two
segments
there's also something we need to do at
the beginning which is to take the input
characters and turn them into partial
solutions
that is done by the subroutine process
char it takes a character in the form of
a singleton string
and promises to return a word state if c
is blank
then it returns an empty segment
consisting of two empty chunks and an
empty list
otherwise it returns a chunk containing
the non-blank character c
which represents this part this word or
partial word that is building up
and here's the final solution words is
the implementation of this solution it
takes the string
s what does it do well there's this
funny line that comes next
just as mathematicians use big sigma
operators to add up a bunch of things
i'm going to use big
o plus to combine a bunch of solutions
so for every value of k
starting from zero and going for the
length of the string
i'm going to extract the substring at
position k
just as i did the sequential version and
then feed that character to process
char now some one of the few things that
the compiler knows about parallelism
is that this body
is going to be executed a number of
times and that all of its instances
may are permitted to be executed in
parallel so all the calls to process
char
are considered independent and it is a
detailed list of implementation as to
whether to execute it sequentially or in
parallel
depending upon the process of resources
available
once we have processed all the
characters into partial solutions
then we hit it with big o plus and the
other thing that the compiler knows in
fact this isn't in the compiler it's
actually built into library subroutines
i said the language is highly user
extensible and in fact this knowledge is
built into libraries rather than the
compiler
but big o plus because it is associative
is entitled to use a binary tree
strategy rather than a sequential
strategy
and therefore all the parallelism in
this solution is in that one line of
code
the parallel calls to process char and
the building of the binary tree
to merge the solutions pairwise all
happens in that big o plus operator
then there's a fix up at the end we've
got this final solution g and we have to
do this type case on g
to find out whether it's a chunk or
segment if it's a chunk maybe it's a
word and we feed it to maybe word
if it's a segment then maybe it's left
in right chunks or words we feed those
to maybe word
concatenate them onto the list in the
middle and we're done and because
chunk and segment comprise word state
that word state
comprises chunk and segment we know that
the type case doesn't need a default
case
these are all the cases that can happen
and lastly
here are about eight lines of
boilerplate needed for the definition of
big o plus in terms of o plus
so that's it that may seem like a lot of
trouble to go to for such a simple
problem
and it is for such a simple problem but
if you've got a problem where
your data is much bigger and the
combining operations are much bigger
then it does make sense to think about
building up partial solutions
independently
and then thinking about how you combine
them and this is the essence of
mapreduce
i'm proposing to use mapreduce at all
scales not just the big honking let's
process
uh terabytes of data scale
the other part of my message is that
algebraic properties are important i've
talked a lot about associativity
and things that we learn in an abstract
algebra course and some of these we
actually encounter in high school maybe
even in grade school if you
were sent through the new math
curriculum as my brother was i've
narrowly escaped it
is the ideas like associativity and
commutativity and item potence and
identities and zeros of an operator are
very
important and people's eyes glaze over
when i mention these five buzz words
but they correspond to simple ideas that
are actually extremely important to
programmers
associativity just means that grouping
doesn't matter you can parenthesize the
expression any way you like
and you'll still get the same answer
knowing that
is important commutativity means the
order doesn't matter i can scramble them
and i'll still get the same result
if i add up a bunch of numbers after
scrambling them still get the same
answer
item potent simply means duplicates
don't matter
if you're taking the max of a bunch of
numbers it's okay if there are
duplicates you'll still get the same
answer
identity means this value doesn't matter
you can afford to discard it and skip
over it if you want to
zero means other values don't matter if
you multiply a bunch of numbers you've
got a zero an end
you can ignore all the others that's the
answer
these invariants give an implementation
wiggle room
that's the buzzword i would like you to
take away today wiggle room for an
implementation is an important idea
it's the freedom to exploit alternate
representations and implementations
not having an address of operator in
java is what gives the garbage collector
the wiggle room
to reallocate memory that sees fit with
c
you never can be sure someone isn't
going to take the address of some data
structure
or two data structures and play some
awful game like xoring the addresses
together and storing that somewhere
and expecting to recover it later which
sounds stupid but they're actually
seriously
serious algorithms in the 1970s made use
of that trick storing two pointers in
one word by xoring them and carefully
having enough information on the side to
reconstruct them
but a garbage collector's not going to
understand that
that's the sort of pun that i exploit in
the ibm 1130 code
associativity gives implementations the
necessary wiggle room to use parallelism
or not as resources dictate
so the big idea is that loops and
summations and another thing like list
or set comprehensions
are really all alike they generate an
abstract collection
there is a body which is a function a
callback function if you will that gets
called for each element in the
collection
and then you combine the results in some
way which might be just to synchronize
before finishing the loop
or it might be producing some result
like a like a concatenated list
or a sum of numbers whether to be
sequential or parallel is actually a
separable and orthogonal question
and in fact in fortress if you want to
be sequential you have to put that seq
on the range if you don't put seq then
the compiler feels entitled to use the
parallel version
and that's why loops and summations and
set comprehensions are such wonderful
abstractions for parallel programming
they allow not just the compiler but the
runtime to make the decision on the fly
based on available resources to decide
whether to whether to break up
subproblems in a linear fashion or in a
divide and conquer fashion
now suppose you've got a sequential loop
and you just can't figure out how to
make the
how to make the iterations independent
suppose that you really do have a bunch
of state and every iteration loop is
doing a bunch of side effects on a bunch
of variables
well here's an eye here's a strategy
gather together all the variables you're
doing side effects on
and consider them to be a state value
now conceptualize the iterations of the
loop as state alteration functions
to transform one state into another
and it might be a different function for
different iterations of the loop if the
loop goes around a million times you
might have a million different functions
that's okay
but if you can find an efficient way to
compute and represent
compositions of these functions and this
step requires ingenuity
then as shown by the third bullet on
this slide instead of doing the
computation
initialize the state s sub zero and keep
iteratively update the state using using
iteration update function f sub
i as i goes from one to million instead
you take the functions f sub i and as i
goes from one to a million
you compose them with big compose
to get one monster function which if
you've represented efficiently isn't so
monster
and then you apply that composed
function to s sub zero and go directly
to the final state
in one step because function composition
is associative
this has a parallel strategy and a lot
of programs that i thought could not be
parallelized in fact succumb to this
technique
and in fact in the words of a string
problem you can regard each input
character is representing
a state transformation function on my
state variables
result and words and depending what the
character does the state gets updated
and i found an efficient representation
for those functions namely the chunks
and the segments
and found a way to compose them
it gets even better than that it turns
out that if you have two sequential
versions of a function
one goes left to right the other goes
right to left and you organize in the
correct functional style it can still be
use the accumulator strategy but
reorganized in a functional style so as
to constitute what's technically called
a list homomorphism
then there's an automatic procedure
where you can turn a crank and get the
parallel divide and conquer version out
all you have to do is divide is to
derive a weak right inverse function and
then apply the third homomorphism
theorem
see it's easy
and see the footnotes for the uh the
papers on that
mapreduce is a really big deal
associative combining operators are a
very big deal
now google map reduce requires the
combining operators also be commutative
and that's okay because typically google
map reduce is applied to
data sets that are already unordered but
if the data set already has a natural
ordering there's
sometimes value in preserving that
ordering and it's important to realize
that order will preser be preserved if
your combining operator is associative
and if the implementation is careful
with respecting the ordering
parallel prefix is an imported related
concept i'm not going to get into
parallel prefix but i just want to
mention that
the other thing i want to mention is
that the idea of inventing new combining
operators i think is going to be an
important paradigm in future programming
for parallelism a lot of parallel
programming languages provide
sort of the big six or seven sum product
logical and logical or and xor and min
and max
and they'll provide a way to find the
max of an array or the sum over an array
but they don't provide a way to give
parallel user defined
operator over ray because they can never
quite be sure that user defined operator
is associative
which is what you need user to find
monoids that's a
term from um from algebra that just
means you have an associative operator
with an identity
creative catamorphism so i'm not going
to get into that either these are
mathematical buzzwords
they refer to the fact that associative
operators are a big deal
and i think we need programming
languages that encourage this without
using all the mathematical terminology
and encourage programmers to realize
just if you can give me the wiggle room
and just make sure that your pro that
that the way i group things doesn't
matter
then i can take care of the parallelism
for you i think that's gonna be an
important important mindset going
forward
do loops are so 1950s
literally fortran is over 50 years old
linear linked lists are so 1950s lisp is
over 50 years old
java style iterators are so last
millennium
but all these are programming patterns
that that if we use them require us to
state our programs in a style that are
very hard to automatically parallelize
as soon as you say well first i'll sum
to zero you're already hosed
accumulators are bad for parallelism and
i've really found it's
even when i'm using a a programming
language that's designed to be
sequential
it's really affected my programming
style just every time i say sum equals
zero or
word equals empty list i stop and think
you know
is this really the way i want to express
myself is this going to be hard to
parallelize down the road
it really makes you stop and think if
you say pr we'll process the problems in
sub-order you lose
the great tricks of the sequential past
are not going to work in the future
and the programming idioms that have
become second nature to many of us
myself included as everyday tools
aren't going to work going forward if we
want to take advantage of the multi-core
computers that are now ubiquitous
we need to get to the point where
parallelism is like memory management
i referred to resource management
problems throughout history registers
and register allocators
the registered declaration in c is an
excellent example
when c was first being developed was
first nascent in an earlier language
called b that was being done on a pdp
seven
that was another one of those one
accumulator machines c came along and
was implemented on the pdp11 it had
eight registers
and you could get better performance by
telling the compiler g if you just put
these two variables in registers
you'll save a lot of memory traffic
and so uh the better compilers observed
the register declarations and allowed
the programmer to thereby get more
performance out of their code
then it reached a point in the 1980s and
i was working for a compiler
construction company
uh in those days and we realized at that
point that only the mediocre compilers
were using the register declarations
the stupid ones were ignoring them as
before and the really smart ones were
also ignoring them because their
register allocators did a much better
job
that a programmer could do just by by
decorating his declarations with the
word register
and we reached that point where we
really don't much bother with registered
decorations anymore except in very
special circumstances
because the register allocation
algorithms have gotten so good they're
better than any human programmer
nearly always similarly for main memory
we rely on garbage collectors virtual
memory
uh in order for caches people spend a
lot of time worrying about
the effects of caches on their code and
for very highly performance critical
applications you still worry about that
but for the bulk of things we can either
use cache oblivious algorithms
self-tuning algorithms such as fftw or
just ignore the issue because the
processes are fast enough
but the key is to maintain an invariant
that gives the implementation wiggle
room
and a good programming language
environment will aid or encourage or
enforce those invariants
one of the advantages of java overseas
it doesn't even have a registered
declaration you don't even have to worry
about that issue
it doesn't have an address operation
address of operator
so you can't even raise the issue of
whether you're playing games with the
addresses
it it uses automatic memory management
so you're not worried about
uh did i leave a pointer dangling just
those things are taken care of for you
now
we need to do for parallelism what what
what memory management has done for data
allocation
we need to do for processor allocations
we don't need to worry about the
processors anymore
so to conclude i believe that a program
organized
according to linear problem
decomposition principles of which the
accumulator design
pattern is a significant hallmark those
sorts of programs can be really hard to
parallelize
a program organized according to
independence
maybe having a programming language
makes it easy to say which computations
are independent
and being able to talk about uh
combining operations in which grouping
doesn't matter
dividing these divide and conquer
principles make for code
that is easily run either in parallel or
sequentially
according to what resources are
available at runtime this new strategy
does have costs and overheads related to
the current way of doing business
just as garbage collectors have costs
and overheads related to the
way of doing business before that we've
come to accept those costs and overheads
because they free us to focus on what's
really important which is getting the
prop
the problem done you know whatever they
are the business rules the scientific
algorithm
and not worry about the details of
managing the computer i believe that in
a world of parallel computers of wildly
varying
sizes which is about to hit us in the
face this will be our only hope for
program portability in the future
and as a programming language designer i
hold up the hope that better language
design can encourage the necessary kind
of
independent thinking to allow parallel
computers to run programs effectively
that's the end of my story thank you
very much